unique qui va durer trois ans.
Anne-Louise Despatie.
- Ça, c'est du thon. Ça, c'est
de la goberge.
Moi, des fois, j'achète trop
encore. T'sais, j'essaie
de planifier de mieux en mieux
Là, j'ai toujours ma montagne
de crudités en partant.
- Marcelle Bastien a toujours eu
le souci de manger sainement.
depuis qu'elle est à
la retraite. Elle vit seule
dans une résidence pour ainés.
MARCELLE BASTIEN, résidente,Sélt
- On a tout le temps voulu
de lire les étiquettes, faire
attention à... bomange, t'sais,,
bien là, OK." Puis, de géres, dr
aussi, des fois, le manque
d'appetit. C'est l
ce que tu mets dans ta machine,
c'est ce faire rouler,
t'sais.
Salut.
personnes à ma place.
- Soucieuse de préserver
son autonomie, elle a participé
qui réunit des étudiantes
tion de l'Université
de Montréal et des résidents
- Dépendamment de chaque
personne âgée, les besoins
en protéines peuvent augmenter
d'au moins 25 %.
- Les étudiantes occupations des
en s'appuyant sur des données
scientifiques.
ANDRÉE TREMBLAY, résidente,
Sélectio- Moi, ce que j'ai appr,
c'est que la personne âgée a
besoin de plus de protéines.
Ce que je ne savais pas.
Sélection Retraite Rosemont
- Toutes les sources
de protéines qu'elles ont
mentionnées, comment
les intéation
tous les jours.
- À lncore plus
griller pour que ça fasse
un petit crunch crunch là.
je trouve ca vraiment
intéressant.
tage a permis de faire
découvrir des astuces pour
introduire plus de protéines- Ç?
- Edamame et ricotta.
- Ça, je vais m'en faire parce
que j'aime ça grignoter avec
mon apéro le soir.
GILLES RIVEST, résident,
Sélection Retraite Rosemont
- Je suis de plus en plusen, mat
c'est pas parfait encore par
que ici, ce n'est pas toujours
possible,meilleur marché que
de la viande. Parce qu'au pr
où est la viande maintenant là,
ça va nous aider.- Une chimie se
entre les deux gén
CÉCILE LAFONTAINE, résidente,
Sélection Retraite
- C'était pas notre facon
de cuisiMais je trouve
que ça, c'est... en tout cas,
pour moi
intéressant d'avoir ce contact
avec lesi nous
apportent des choses nouvelles.
étudiante en nutrition, UdeM
a formation, je ne
les avais pas vraiment vues,
cette clientèle-là. Donc,
personnes aînées plus en CHSLDde
dans la vie. Puis, ici, bien
on les voit vraime
MARIE MARQUIS, directrice,
Département de nutrition, UdeM
- Ce n'est pas des personnes
qu'on a l'habitude programme prs
de formation, alors que c'est
c d'aujourd'hui et ça va
être aussi le Québec de demain.
D'ici 10 ans, on prévoit à peua.
- Le projet s'étale sur 3 ansgre
Sélection retraite qui permet
aux étudiantes d'installer
pendant les stages et
les projets spéciaux.
- Ça fait que la cuisine, ici,
la direction est sensible
à cet... ce fait-là. Puis,
l'alimentaiton, il faut que
de protéines, c'était certain
pour nous qu'on aborderait
les protéines végétales, et
aussi : "bien, les protéines
végétales, on n'a pas le choix,
on va se diriger vers elles pour
durable, mais on va se diriger
vers elle également compte tenu
de notre portefeuille."
et les vidéos destinées aux
ainés autonomes seront partagées
dans l'ensemble des résidences..
Éventuellement, le grand public
y a aura aussi accès.
Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, Mon